Welcome to Ear Biscuits podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table, a dim lighting,
a decision has been thrust
upon me and my family.
Thrust.
And before a final decision is made,
I wanna use this forum to talk it through,
because this is no light decision.
This may be one of the
most difficult decisions
that we've ever made as a family.
And I'm teasing this as
if people who listen,
don't read the title of the podcast
and they don't know
what I'm talking about.
Maybe some people just--
The title something like,
should Link get a cat?
Yeah, should Link's family get a kitten?
Which becomes a cat and
that's the first point,
but that didn't shut it down.
So there's been a whole conversation
and I'd like to bring it
here to the table Rhett.
Well, I've got lots of the thoughts.
Oh my gosh, and yeah--
And I did some research for you,
I just wanna let you know.
Oh really?
Boop dboop I did some research.
Boop dboop.
This may turn into one of those podcasts
where it's like I'm airing
out all of my inner turmoil
and getting your opinion on it.
Because before we get into that,
I do have something else
that I'm grappling with
that I don't think will
take that long but--
Are using a grappling hook?
It's bothered me.
No, I'm just using self analysis.
And when I share the story,
I'm gonna share with you.
With my family, I didn't
get the response I wanted.
I was like, "Oh my gosh, am I a creep?"
Before you share that,
do you want to acknowledge the nature
of our conversation last week?
I think we should probably--
We should yeah.
Do it as quickly.
As you know things got deeply real
one episode turned into two.
We're recording this episode
before that episode part two
of the conversation is released.
So that means that we haven't seen
what you think about it
yet, how you've responded.
So we're going to--
But it's been a week since
you've listened to it.
If you're listening as these come out.
So we anticipate that you weighed in
on the conversation using #EarBiscuits,
which if you haven't, it's not too late.
As always use #EarBiscuits
to be a part of this conversation.
Right, and we don't know...
We could continue the conversation,
we could just have a follow up,
but we just didn't wanna do it until
we hear your thoughts on it.
Yeah, so, we're open to continuing
the conversation publicly
in some form or another.
If the public discourse calls for it,
if not, we'll just move on.
It's not like we didn't
continue to talk about it
for two more hours--
We talked about it.
After that podcast.
And we're still good.
We're still good.
We were good and we're still good.
Don't worry about us.
That's right.
Well, teach yourself.
But you're not making eye contact.
Okay, but that's too much eye contact.
Because it hurts my neck.
Okay, okay.
My next too.
I like to look into my...
Actually, I don't ever
look into my camera.
You probably look into that camera a lot.
I do some times.
You're a camera Looker.
Yeah.
I'm not a camera looker.
Yeah. I'll look into that camera.
If I wanna emphasize
my opinion on something
you're saying non-verbally.
I wonder how many times
I've actually looked
into the camera that's filming me.
I don't believe that it's many.
I go through life looking for a camera
to communicate with non-verbally.
It's true, we can have a
conversation about that too.
That's another one.
I guess this first thing is related to,
well, camera's a little bit.
My kids are well into a school
and I opened the door
and they've got this screen
and there's all of these kids
with their faces on the screen.
And it's so weird to be
doing class over Zoom.
I'm not doing it.
And I really hadn't experienced it.
Is it an extended?
My kids don't start until
the next week, by the way.
It's really late for the school.
Is it like, "Hey, we're in class
from eight o'clock until 2:00 pm?"
Pretty much, yeah.
One continuous.
No, it's not--
'Cause you got to go
to different teachers.
It's high schoolers.
Yeah, Lando doesn't.
But Shepherd is gonna have
the same teacher the whole day.
Yeah, Lando's got the same teacher.
There's one class that switches out
and I haven't asked him
exactly how that works,
but they've got a scheduled in breaks
and he gets up and moves around.
I heard some banging in
there and he was like--
Drunkless.
He's doing PE, he was doing calisthenics.
Oh wow.
In his bedroom.
I was like, "Okay."
With the camera on?
Yeah, he was falling along
with the Instructional thing.
That's tough.
But the thing I realized was,
well, we've been conducting
so much of our business
and teamwork and coordination and meetings
on Zoom for months and
months and months now.
But that's totally different
than being in a class.
But we did get a taste of it whenever...
As a company, we're doing a class,
I don't wanna get into
the specifics of it,
but it's just pertinent to say
in a totally different mode,
than how we conduct our
business meetings over Zoom.
We're all attending
these enrichment classes.
So we're all basically students
for that one hour every
week or every other week.
And that's as close as
I feel like I've come
to what it feels like
to be my kids in school
in remote electronic learning.
And something happened
there that I observed that,
I don't know.
It just disturbed me a little bit.
On Reddit, there's a thread called
Am I The Asshole?
Where somebody posts
something that happens to them
and how they contributed to a situation.
And the question up for debate is,
was I the asshole in this situation?
And the best ones are the ones
where the title seems to spell out,
what I did makes me an asshole.
But then when they describe it,
the really good ones change
your mind because the details.
My question to you is--
Yeah, you're the asshole.
Am I--
No, it's a slightly different question.
It's, am I a creep?
Okay.
Here's what happened.
We were in one of these...
You were in it too.
We were both in this class of sorts and--
I know where you're going
with this by the way,
but I'm not gonna say anything.
Okay, you got to tell me.
Okay. All right.
Here's what happened.
I debated whether to talk about this
because it was very...
I wanted it to be clear up top
and I hopefully I've made it clear
if any of our employees are listening,
that this is a different
venue and I haven't done this
with anybody that--
I know what you're going to say.
That works for me.
And yes, I have done it.
Okay, so I'm looking at the screen
and it's a class, your mind,
I'm paying attention,
but it's just somebody talking.
And they'll usually put
a presentation slide up.
And the thing with a slide
is you can read everything
on the slide like that
but they've only read through half of it.
So I'm like, "Okay, I
know where this is going.
I've read the second half of the slide.
So what am I gonna do now?
I'm gonna look around at the other people
and see if they're paying attention."
And I noticed that one
person who was sending...
With the webcam on,
we basically all had our webcams on,
by the way, for my kids, they're required
to have their webcams on.
You can't turn it off and say
that you're paying attention.
Of course.
Which makes sense.
Looks like you just like put
a sheet over yourself in class,
same principle.
I'm putting it on my privacy sheet.
Has one of your kids
got in trouble for that?
You had to say it was your idea.
Yeah. It was a tarp.
A privacy tarp.
I noticed this one
person in the background,
they're sitting in the foreground,
right in front of their webcam,
but in the background over
this person's shoulder,
I see one of the far walls
is decorated with albums.
I'm like, "Oh, I did that
in our creative house."
Okay, this is going in
a different direction.
Oh, it is.
So then I went over and
I pinned this person
and made them full screen.
So I could see if I could
identify their albums.
And so I'm looking over
this person's shoulder,
happens to be a woman.
To me that's not pertinent--
But you did mention it.
And I'm looking--
As if it might be.
I'm looking over her
shoulder at her albums.
And I'm leaning in,
I'm like, "I don't recognize
any of these albums."
It was like--
And then she's like,
"What are you looking at?"
That's not how it works in
2030, that's how it will work.
I'm like, "I recognize
that Harry styles album,
the one with watermelon sugar on it."
Okay, you're really narrowing it down.
Whoever this is, is gonna know who it was.
Yeah, maybe that's why I
shouldn't be talking about it.
It's someone who works for us,
who was a woman who has
albums in the background.
No, it's not someone who works for us.
It's someone who works for the company--
Company who's doing the training
That's putting on the class.
I do not know this person--
That changes things.
This person does not work for me.
That's important to me.
Because then as I'm
looking at these albums,
my eyes move over a little bit.
And there she is.
And I'm like, "Oh my
gosh, this feels creepy."
Meaning I'm starting to feel like creep.
And like unpender.
And I was like, "Oh my gosh,
what have I done? Who am I?
Because it felt weird that
I was like scrutinizing
this person's decor.
But then I'm like, "That's borderline."
People could pin anybody they wanted
and just stare a person down.
That's what I do.
You please take the hid off
me and tell me about it.
I knew this is what you were gonna say.
It went a slightly different direction.
And it's interesting that
you found this ability,
it seems more recently.
Well, I know you can pin people but--
No, no you--
Pin people who aren't talking?
You began to--
And don't know you're looking at them.
Practice this.
I think this happened pretty
early on for me in COVID.
But my motivation for doing it,
which is we're in a big meeting
and everybody's listening.
And I click on people so I
can see if they seem engaged,
if they're processing something.
Is this a meeting that you're leading?
I think the first time I did it,
was in a senior staff meeting
that we did as Zoom.
Sometimes I'm like,
"This person is talking about this,
does this person who isn't
directly related to this?"
I'm asking the question
of an employer, of a boss.
It's like--
Yeah, you're.
Are they engaged?
It's a valid question when you're...
If you're sitting around
a boardroom table,
which we normally do
with our staff meeting.
And I would look at a person who's like,
"Is so and so listening to so-and-so
and should they be?"
I'm thinking things like that. Right?
Yeah.
And then more recently
with the training classes--
But hold on, with that
boardroom you're telling me
that you pinned someone who was listening
to someone else talking in order
to analyze if they were engaged?
Yeah.
And then did you feel
a pang of creepiness?
This is the analogy that I use.
So sometimes I go on a walk at night.
And go up to people's windows.
And I'm walking.
There are some houses
that the biggest window
in the front of the house
is into their living room.
And you can see what they're
watching on television.
Oh, I've done this.
I don't stop walking.
You don't stop walking, do you?
Not usually,
if they're watching something
really interesting--
You don't like square
up, turn your shoulders.
No, but you know what
happened the other night?
Was walking and I looked
into somebody's living room.
Basically what I'm saying is
when you got your blinds open at night--
Is permission.
Your living room, my
understanding is you're saying,
"Yeah, you can look at my house."
And that's how I felt ultimately
about the album collection.
I was like, "This person set up the shot."
Yes, they framed it.
They framed the shot.
So everything's--
They set dressed their own Zoom shot.
Everything in the frame
is fine for people to see,
because they've set up that shot.
No, I don't feel that way
about the bedroom window.
I'm not a peeping Tom.
I don't go to the side yard and look into,
that's off limits.
But I'm in the street, I
haven't left the sidewalk.
I'm not in your yard. I may slow down.
I slowed down the other night
because I passed a house.
And I was like,
"What is that they're
watching on television?"
Oh, this is a new one, this show.
And I was like, "They have a security feed
of their driveway on their television.
And that's why I'm currently
on the television."
What?
Oh what?
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's not that exciting.
It is, that's crazy.
And now--
Did you wave?
No, but now every time
I walk by, I'm like,
"There's the house, that's
got the security feed
of the driveway very prominent
in the living room facing back."
Were they seated in there watching it?
No, it's just constantly.
If they're not watching television,
they've got a security
feed of the driveway
on the living room television.
I can do that.
Well, I could probably do it too.
Is this a contest?
You're competitive.
I know and I'm just saying.
I'm saying with the nest cam
in their global com crashed.
You can cast your screen.
You have the capability doing that.
If I'm expecting guests,
sometimes I'll put it up there.
They must always be expecting guests.
It's hilarious that you
stopped and saw yourself--
But in their--
On their telephone.
Here's the thing though.
Here's what I've concluded.
They know this is how it works,
because why would they
leave the window open
and have the television
where you can clearly see?
I actually think it might
be for like intruders.
It might be like, "Anybody
who comes into our driveway
will see themselves in our driveway,
that we're seeing on this feed."
Because you would put it
in like a different room
if you didn't want people...
So what I'm saying is, that Zoom window
in a video conference is
your public facing window.
And so I fee...
Now, if I'm just like,
"I'm gonna click on this
person and just look at them."
Which is not what I've done.
Just watch them, to watch them.
I don't even know why
I would do that, but--
To see what it feels like to be creepy.
For the training exercises,
again, like you say, we're in this class
and this is a night and we'd
probably ended up talking
about what the training is later.
We're just in the early
stages of it right now.
This was our idea.
It was our idea for everyone
to go through this training.
And I am thinking like, "Are they getting
what they need out of this?
Do they seem engaged?"
Oh, so you pin other--
I pin multiple employees.
And you could tell by
the way I told the story
that I felt comfortable
pinning someone I didn't know
who I was taking a class from.
First is pinning someone
who worked for me.
I think if they heard that I'm just afraid
they would be creeped out.
I don't pin them for an
extended period of time.
'Cause you can't see everybody
Yeah, you can't see everybody.
So everybody I ca see if they're like,
"Oh, this person."
But if it's like, "That person looks mad
or that person looks disengaged."
I might click on them and be like,
"Am I getting the right
impression from them right now?"
And it might be a five second checking in
like, okay. All right.
But they looked mad, but they just--
Do you feel...
And again, I'm really on the fence,
I'm legitimately asking,
do you feel okay about this
because you're the boss
and there's like a
professional motive associated?
I would feel fine if they did it to me.
I thought that I was going to need
to develop some approach of like,
"Okay, I'm gonna direct
message this person
and say, "Would you mind if I pinned you
so that I could see take a
closer look at your albums?"
You're seeing that's worse.
The difference between me and you is that,
I'll just look at their
albums and feel no remorse.
And you'll send a message that actually--
Makes it worse?
Makes it worse.
Now that we're talking about it--
Confession makes things worse,
but then they relieve burdens.
Now, if I had the ability,
I don't know how to do this,
I'm sure there are people who can do this.
If I had the ability to...
If I see a message on
that's intended for you,
I shouldn't read that.
If I had the ability...
Well, I was getting to hacking,
I do have the ability to
read a message on a phone.
I'm sorry,
I lost my train of thought.
But what I was getting at is,
some people can hack your
security cameras at home.
And look at what you're
seeing on your nest camera.
Really?
Yeah.
And this is why you need two
step authentication, but...
I'm sure you already have it set up.
But if you didn't and someone
was able to get into your...
Obviously that's a violation
of someone's privacy
because they think that
this video feed is for them.
But when I'm on a video conference,
my assumption is anybody could
be looking at me right now.
I think we just need to send out.
Talking about the difference
between somebody being small
on your screen
A memo.
And somebody being big on your screen.
If you got a big ass monitor already--
The small is the big?
The small people
are already big.
So there's a gray area here.
I just think that this is your open...
In fact, the living room window
thing is not a great analogy
because if you were watching
television in your living room
and you saw a tall man slowly
walking in your front yard,
looking at what you're
watching on television,
you'd feel a little violated because
the window isn't open.
Unless you were watching.
Right.
And then it's Whoa, that's a tit for tat.
Yeah, so I just think that this is
like a drive through window.
You open it and of course
you can look behind me.
This is my public facing window.
I just don't think people are aware of it.
I feel like there needs to be a warning,
and maybe remember--
You're being--
You can be watched in
full screen at any moment.
So watch your resting faces--
I think everybody already--
But try to stay engaged.
Knows this.
It's easy to forget.
Yeah, you started scratching an itch,
before you know people are watching
and that itch could be anywhere.
Okay, amendment to my idea.
If I had somebody pinned
for investigatory purposes,
I'm not even sure if that's the word
and they began to do
something embarrassing.
And it was clear to me
that they had forgotten
that they could be pinned at
any point, booger picking,
something more salacious, whatever.
At that point, I feel it
would be my moral obligation
to unpin them.
And maybe even send them a message,
"Hey, you're on chat. Don't forget that."
And you're big on my screen.
You were coming up big.
Is that Eric Clapton on
that album behind you?
I would have recognized
Eric Clapton, slow hand.
I also wonder, should we send out a memo?
I'm not gonna single you out
I think we've done that by making--
And just say--
It on the podcast.
"Hey know what employees?
Just to remember at any moment,
you could become up big for Rhett."
I think we just in the general Slack
before the next training meeting, we say,
"Please listen to the latest
episode of Ear Biscuits."
Gosh.
Because you should be doing it in any way.
I don't know, man.
I feel like I'm never
gonna pin anyone again.
And now you're gonna
be pinning constantly.
How did that happen?
I'll do all the pinning
for the both of us.
I gotta tell this story,
I got to throw my son under the bus,
take some of the heat off of me.
Lincoln, who's 15, he's
just getting started.
And he at the dinner table,
I was asking about class
and how does it work with Zoom?
And he got this sheepish look on his face
that he's about to tell a Lincoln story.
And so we all get excited about that.
And he's like, "Well...
I don't remember which class it was.
And he was like, "I was making a noise
to myself during class.
I was like,
I'm like, 'What?"
Oh, God.
What is that noise?
He's like, "I don't know, I was bored.
I was just making a noise."
He's like, " "
I was like, "It sounds
like you were dying."
Oh my God.
I'm just like,
that's your boredom noise?
And he's like--
Oh God.
"Yeah, it sounds like, "
And then all of a sudden I looked
and I got big on the screen
and I realized I wasn't muted.
Yeah, that's how it works Link.
And then Lincoln said...
'Cause everyone's automatically muted,
usually in a classroom.
And he said that the teacher said,
"We gotta mute that boy."
In front of everybody and
then Lincoln was like...
He was there like, "I sent a
private message to my teacher.
And I was like, "I am so sorry,
I thought I was on mute."
I was like, "But you didn't explain
why you were making the death noise?"
If there was ever any doubt--
That Lincoln is of your loins,
you do not need a paternity test.
What if I was doing that
while you were talking,
thinking I was muted?
Wow, death noise.
I'm glad we solved that one.
'Cause now we've gotta
solve this cat problem.
Okay. But first, what are we trying
to get people interested
in this weak Link?
We're trying to get people interested in--
That's an old shirt right there.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, Kiko told me.
Don't tell me Kiko.
I'm not gonna remember these two things--
The travel mug?
No.
I may have just revealed
something that I shouldn't have.
What is it?
Oh, hair tie.
You got a hair tie?
Mythical hair tie.
I'm actually using another
hair tie at the moment.
Just because they gave me some--
You gotta go to mythical.com.
They gave me some for a photo shoot.
And what's the other one Kiko?
And then they took them back.
Shoelaces.
Yeah, we got hair ties and shoelaces.
We're expanding around here.
'Cause you don't need to use
shoelaces to tie your hair
and don't need--
You can though.
These hair ties-
In a
To tie your shoes.
That would be tough.
We have both mythical.com.
Rep your boys on your
feet and on your head
and everywhere in between
before things go out of
circulation like this shirt,
which is one of my favorites.
Can I ask you one question before
you get started about this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The timing of this is interesting, right?
I know it is.
Because just other night,
not the other night,
the other day when we were
at the creative house,
our kids both...
All of our kids have taken
to using the creative house,
is they're like, I don't
know, like their getaway.
And LUck will be like,
"Dad, gonna go to creative house today?"
I'm like, "Okay."
He hasn't even started school yet.
And I'm just like, "Why do
you like going over there?"
He's like, "Oh, it's like get away."
Yeah, exactly.
It's just you get to go over to the house.
So Lily has come over a number
of times to do some work.
And when she came over the other day,
she was like, "Hey Rhett,
I think we might get a cat.
Or I think I might get a cat."
And she was obviously trying
to instigate something,
a conversation.
But I assume that she doesn't
for her own good listen to this podcast.
She doesn't know about my
encounters with the cat.
She doesn't know about
the soft place in my heart
that I now have for cats.
No, Rhett, Lily has taste.
And she listens to Dear Hank and John.
Okay, you're right. She's too smart.
She knows what's up.
So you're just saying,
this makes it even more interesting.
You're just saying it's serendipity.
It's potentially destiny.
She knows your reputation of hating cats.
She doesn't know the update.
Wow.
'Cause you're bringing this into
a very different environment.
If you had a brought this proposal
into Rhett from two months ago,
I would have a completely different.
But my--
You're talking about-
Attitude towards cats has changed.
Because you had--
Or cat.
You had a run in with cat that
you gave your love to this
cat, and now it's gone.
And presumably dead.
Some people got upset with me
that I presumed it was dead.
But listen, just the other night,
right before I went past the house
and it's on myself on
someone's television.
I went past the cat house.
We always go past there.
Still no cat?
Still a sign up, still lost.
The cat's not coming back.
Has your heart grown?
I got to say that.
I'm like, "Man, what are the chances
I can find another cat like that?"
That was a highlight of those walks.
Now I do have the ability to
see myself on the television,
which is, I definitely go
by that house every time.
That's a highlight now.
Which is just a substitute for the cat.
No, it's funny because
it was getting to the point where...
'Cause all these people
followed up after that podcast
and were like, "Oh yeah, Tabbies."
They're called tabbies, the orange tabby.
Oh yeah, those are always
really, really friendly.
Oh, you know what?
Also a Maine Coon it is
the official cat of Maine.
They're huge.
They're very sweet too.
They're very doglike, I had heard that.
'Cause we've got some
friends who got a Maine Coon.
A lot of hair though.
And so, yeah, I'm sure allergic to...
Anyway, this is gonna fall on soft ears,
but I will say-
It's interesting.
I have something that might give you pause
and that's not a pun.
But it is a good one.
So yeah, I meant to say pause.
So the other night,
well, Lily hardly ever texts me.
She's beginning her senior
year, I feel for her.
That's tough.
Because it's their senior
year of high school
and here she is just doing it on a screen,
getting pinned on
knowingly by creeper guys--
Yeah, ready year one.
I'm freaking concerned,
I'm just a little sad she's doing well,
all things considered,
but it's just a bummer.
So she texts me and like a per cup.
'Cause I'm like, she
sent me a pic of a cat.
That was just it.
Okay, that's smart.
And then I didn't know how to respond.
Then I got distracted.
Is there something particular
about the cat--
I didn't respond.
Was it doing something funny?
Was it skateboarding?
On a second look,
the cat was in her lap.
When I got home,
I could tell--
In Lily's lap?
Yeah, in her lap 'cause it was her shorts.
But when I got home,
we were eating dinner
or about to eat dinner.
And this is like family conversation time.
But she says, "Dad, there's someone needs
to talk to you about."
And I'm like, "Okay."
And I'm thinking dinner.
She's like, "After dinner."
Oh, okay. That's interesting.
You don't talk about, oh.
This doesn't need to be
for the whole family,
this just needs to be for me.
It's what I thought.
And then when dinner was over,
honestly, I'd gotten distracted.
I'd gone into police mode of make sure
all the dishes are done.
Yeah, that's pleasant.
But someone that's not me.
I'm not fun to live with sometimes.
And she's like, "Dad, I need
you to come sit on the couch."
I was like, "Oh my God, is
this a freaking intervention?"
And then she turns on the television
and she standing and smiling
like she knew what was up.
And all of a sudden I look on the screen
and it is the first
slide of a presentation
that she has created that I
would now with her permission,
like to share with you.
Let me pull this in here.
Oops, oh, here it is.
As you can see,
it's a beautiful orange hue background
with white bold lettering.
If you're not watching this
and you wanna watch this,
Ear Biscuit, YouTube
channel, every Sunday,
we released the video version.
It's got all the visuals, including this,
big, bold white letters.
Reasons why you should
let me get a kitten.
And then it hits me.
This is the presentation she
actually talked me into...
Well, it's pretty obvious.
Yeah, it's the thesis is in the title.
It's very straight.
She hit me over the head with it,
which she knows how to
communicate with dad.
It's like hit him hard so
that he's not confused.
And then in little letters
it says Featuring Yeti.
Which I presume is a cat.
I didn't know at this point.
Or she's just gonna use
like a Yeti microphone.
And then down here it says,
Listen to me ... I'm for real,
I can be very persuading.
That's good, that's a really good start.
I would have said I
could be very persuasive,
but I don't think grammatically.
You know what's-
She was there but her were on point.
You know what's interesting about this?
Is this a thing that the youth are doing?
Because for mother's day this year
I told Luck and Shepherd.
I was like, "Guys, you gotta go all out,
you don't do anything.
You just live here and you eat.
And you're here all the time.
You drive your mom crazy.
Do something cool, show some effort."
And--
I remember you telling me about this.
Shepard wrote her an
original song called Mom.
Now it was just a piano,
just an instrumental,
but it was beautiful, I recorded it.
She loved it.
I think she may have cried a little bit.
We listened to that and then I was like,
"Luck, what did you do?"
And he was like, "Oh, oh."
He got this look on his face like
you won't believe what I did.
And then he said,
"Mom, come into the
living room and sit down."
And he was casting a
presentation onto the television.
And he led a presentation about Jessie
and how awesome of a mom she was.
Brilliant.
So are kids doing presentations
because that's something
to get excited about?
We can complain about generation,
whatever they're right now, all we want.
But if they're doing
presentations, there's hope.
That's the brilliant
manipulation of it all Rhett.
'Cause she knew that you
would love a presentation.
Yes.
I would venture to guess if we went
to the right realms of TickTock,
all the children are talking about,
"Hey kids, you wanna get
what you want out of life.
You wanna wrap your parents
around your finger?"
Present something to them.
"Present something to them.
Pick a font and a color and have add."
Because it gives you the idea
that your kids might one
day be gainfully employed.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
If you can do this--
Oh, you could do business.
Half, there I say 75%--
80%.
80%-
Of corporate success.
Is presentation.
If you can do a presentation--
Presentation, bullshit.
You will win at life.
Yeah, where would we
be without PowerPoint?
Right, man.
Okay. I'm really interested in this.
And I perked up.
As you shouldn't.
I perked up.
Slide two.
Now you see there's a picture of cat.
Reason number one, the cuteness factor.
And then on the right,
there's a picture,
it's the picture that she texted me.
Apparently, when I did not
respond to the text at all,
she was like, "That didn't
work, I got to up my game."
And that's when the
presentation came about.
I didn't ask her that,
but above the picture,
it says his name is Yeti.
And it's this white kitten,
a few weeks old sitting on...
That's Lily's lap.
Those are her purple pants.
And then underneath it, it
just says, just look at it.
This is smart 'cause this is--
The cat is looking right into my thought.
There are a few principles in advertising
that she is really doing effectively here.
The first one is the
fact that she exposed you
to a picture of the cat,
just out of the blue.
So this is a repeated
exposure to the idea.
And people have to see and
hear things multiple times
in order to actually take action.
So the fact that she seated
the cat earlier in the day,
really, really smart.
Maybe she should go into advertising.
Now she has this friend
who's fostering kittens
before they're adopted.
So she goes over and
hangs out with this person
and has told me that,
"All these cats, so cute,
you gotta see these little kittens."
So I was aware that this was happening,
but I didn't really see this.
Is that cat going to turn red, orange?
It looks--
it's a white cat with
this little tinge of...
It looks like brown, it could be orange--
It looks friendly.
Some blue eyes.
At this point I'm like, she's not saying,
"Dad, I want this Kitten.
She's saying, "Dad--"
I want this kitten.
"I want this kitten."
It's staring into your
soul, it's name is Yeti.
I liked that name.
Slide three,
reason number two,
listen, anxiety is a real
problem, cats can help.
Here are some facts for you.
Cats lower your stress
level, cats lower anxiety
because they take less effort than dogs.
Petting a cat has a
positive calming effect.
That's good.
And finally, 84% of people say that
their feline friend had a
positive impact on their life.
And there's two pictures of this.
We're in a stock photo territory now,
About kittens exclusively.
Of kittens, make an eye contact,
again with my soul.
This is good. This is good.
But I'm starting to put up
walls and thinking, okay.
You might be in the 16%
The anxiety thing, I feel like at best,
it's probably a wash.
Bringing in another
creature into my house,
raises my anxiety.
I have a lot of questions,
but you know what?
I made up my mind.
Hold the questions to the end.
I'm not gonna interject.
And I'm gonna try to
make a demurring face,
which is hard to interpret.
That's a vocabulary word.
Next slide.
Reason number three,
Jade will have friend.
This is the weakest point, but proceed.
Studies show that it
is extremely important
for dogs to be socialized.
Constant socialization will help Jade
with her aggression towards
people and other animals.
So there's a picture of Jade.
If you want more of those,
then go to Jade the
official Instagram channel.
I think that picture is on it.
Boy, she cute.
Look how cute that dog is.
And just below it is Yeti, the cat.
And then there's a caption,
Can't you just picture them
being the best of friends?
Look how cute they're together.
Wow.
And--
They're not really together,
they've been put together
on a presentation.
So that feels manipulative.
Yeah.
Now, if she had gone the extra mile
to Photoshop them
together, I'd be listening.
But I think that this is the problem here
is I can't picture them
being the best of friends
because I've had experience with Jade.
However--
Now, Jade and Barbara are best of friends.
But Jade was better with the cat--
In
In my house than Barbara was.
The prevailing theory there is that
they were in a neutral territory for Jade,
it was not Jade's home.
But it was Barbara's home
and she was freaked out.
Because Barbara loved the last cat.
I can feel many listeners at this point,
having lots more knowledge about
introducing cats to dogs
and all the dynamics there
and picking apart her argument.
I'm not privy to that information.
So the way that...
But more to come on that.
So don't get too worked up.
For now I'll just say,
there's a weakness in her
argument here with number three,
because our second point
highlights a problem,
which is constant
socialization will help Jade
with her aggression towards
people and other animals.
It's basically saying Jade
is aggressive towards--
But she had to address this point.
You could have argued,
"Listen, don't bring it up."
But it's such a concern.
It's the leading concern.
So she couched it, she made
it reason number three.
So I understand why she included it.
But I think--
I think that she shouldn't included.
Lily could be a lawyer.
Well, let's not get ahead of ourselves.
Well, do they do PowerPoint in courtrooms?
Yes, she could be.
The thing that I'm looking for here
is some relevant facts about how...
She just said constant
socialization will help Jade
with her aggression.
I need some data to back that up.
'Cause I know that Stevie
has a cat and a dog and--
I was thinking about that a lot.
And I'm like, "I think Stevie
does not like her cat."
Oh, don't speak for Stevie.
I'm not gonna...
I said I think, I could be wrong.
I just know that--
I know she loves her dog.
I know that the dog and the cat
are not on the best of terms.
But they can be in the same room.
Well, yeah.
They don't hate each other.
Next slide.
Reason number four, cats pretty much
do everything themselves.
Now the picture of a kitty
and then a picture of a trash can
with the sign litter on it which--
Almost looks like a coffin.
They can go to the bathroom and bathe
without any help or training, how's that?
That's interesting.
But don't worry, I'll keep
the litter box in my closet.
That doesn't make me feel great.
It made me feel good.
I said, "Okay, this is
gonna be your problem.
But I have some concerns
I'll get to you later."
Okay, now I have what might be for you
if you've never heard about it,
a mindblowing little path
that I wanna take you down
that is relevant to reason number four.
Now, we can come back to it.
I don't know how many reasons there are
in this presentation but--
I think there might be one more.
The litter box in the
closet raises concerns
that I feel I need to inform
you as a friend about,
but I'm gonna take you down a path though,
so it's gonna take some time.
Let me get through the rest of this.
'Cause I wanna say what
my response to her was.
So I'll go through the
rest of the presentation,
reason number five,
Yeti and I can even make
the same demonized face.
Look, it's a picture of
the cat getting scrubbed
on her neck by Lily.
And then it's a closeup
and our right eyes,
looking out to the right
and our left eyes looking
a little off to the left.
And this is something that the it clown--
Can do, yeah.
He can--
On command.
And Lily can do that.
And it scares the crap out
of me when she does it.
She looks down and then
her eyes go up and out
and it's like the demon's
trying to pop out of her brain.
So she has a connection to this cat.
But how come she didn't
put her face on there?
Because she knew it would
scare the crap out of me.
Final slide, bold letters
right in the middle.
That is my pitch in smaller letters.
Please let me get a kid.
And then I look over
at her from the screen
and my daughter, she's my first born.
I love her deeply.
I'm super proud of her.
I'm beaming with pride,
that she has constructed a
cohesive set of arguments
and formed it into a presentation.
And I just can't deny.
And I'm like, "The way that I respond."
This is--
She will remember it
for the rest of her life.
And here's the thing with teenagers.
I'm keenly aware that every
time they go out on a limb
with either to assert
themselves, to take a risk,
to share feelings, what's
going on inside of themselves?
It's always precarious because
I felt like any time you
respond to a teenager,
it feels like your entire
relationship is riding on it.
Well, especially now 'cause--
Especially now--
Because if I gave this
presentation to my dad,
he'd be like, "Nope."
And then he would just walk out.
And I still have a good
relationship with him.
But if I were to do that to my kids--
The terms of our relationship--
They fall apart.
Are a little different, and I don't know,
you can pass your own
judgment on what that is,
but you wanna keep connection going.
You wanna keep communication lines open.
You know what?
They can't get everything they want,
but you have to do it in a way that
it doesn't close them off to you because
their predisposition is
to close themselves off.
I'm speaking in generalities,
and Lily may not say that,
but I'm speaking less from the reality
of our relationship and more
from fear of how it may work.
And even when Christine,
I talked about it later,
we were like, "I don't really want a cat,
but I don't wanna make her this upset
about something she's so passionate about
at a time we were looking for
positive things to experience.
I was like, I just need to be
really calculated my response.
And I was like, "First
thing I need to say needs
to be positive and affirming.
I was like, "You know what?
Lily, I wanna commend you
on making this presentation,
on taking the time to do
it and everything in it.
And I just want to acknowledge that
if it were not for you,
Jade would not be a part of our lives.
And that decision, she found
Jade at an adoption thing.
And she brought us all over and said,
"I want this puppy, we need this puppy."
And the first picture I
have is the two of them,
like at that moment,
because Christy wasn't there
and I texted her the picture and stuff.
So I acknowledged that
and I was like, "So I'm
gonna hear you out."
I was like, "Second thing
I need to point out is,
in 10 months from now,
you're gonna be gone.
And if you go off to college,
most likely you're not gonna be able
to take this cat with you.
This is a family decision to have a cat."
This isn't her getting a cat,
this is you getting a cat.
This is you getting a
cat for 10 months or so.
And in us getting the cat
for the rest of the time it's here.
20 years maybe.
And that really concerns me.
I'm also really concerned
about the impact of Jade.
I don't want Jade's feelings to be hurt.
Well, they will be at least initially.
And if there's anybody that I spoil
without any argument, it is Jade.
I got no defense for that.
And I'm not proud of it, but
it does happen constantly.
So I think about her and then I'm like,
"I need to know if there's..."
If this were to happen,
I'm not saying it will.
I'm not saying I'm on board
and all of us have to be on board.
Lando was there the whole
time begging for it to happen.
He's on board.
Lincoln seemed to be on board,
but didn't care because
he's really close to Jade.
He's making death noises.
She sleeps with him now and he's like,
Christy does not want a cat.
Christy wants another dog.
Well, that's what I was gonna ask you,
'cause it feels like-
And I was warming up.
The the only person
who's opinion really
matters in this situation
is Christy's.
And Christy's like, "I'm
concerned about the fact that
I want us to have another dog,
and I don't want this to keep us from that
ultimately to where we were
boxed out of that decision."
And also, she loves plants
more than she loves me.
And so she was very
concerned about the plants,
'Cause cats will eat the plants.
Cats the plants--
That cat ate plants in my house.
Some cats will die because
they eat the wrong plants.
You got to think about your plants
and a plant person doesn't
wanna think about their plants.
And I was like, "Lily, you
need to address the plants.
You need to do research on that.
I need to know if there's a trial period.
I need to know how would we
introduce the two of them?
I need you to do research on that."
And we have to face the fact that like,
they may not get along.
Making a true test.
We cannot just relegate
a cat that in 10 months,
you're gonna be gone that has
to be isolated from our dog.
We can't live that way.
But you could go feral after 10 months.
I'm like, "Real talk, we
have to have an actual trial.
If this were to move forward
and a possible outcome
is that we have to give the cat back
because it's not good for the
cat or the dog or our family.
And you would have to be ready for that."
So she went back and did a research.
She did a second presentation,
which I'm not gonna show you.
I'm not gonna go through it,
but this is what it looked like.
You can see it here.
Mostly text.
It's just white.
There's no more passion
in it, it's just text.
And all it does is
it walks through
how to introduce a cat
to a home with a dog.
This could have been an email,
but I appreciate the effort.
So we're up to speed on
what it takes step by step,
over weeks to introduce a kitten
to a dog, to have a chance.
This is like a multi
month trial by this one.
By the time you've gotten through it,
she's gonna be off to college.
But the last thing I said was,
"Lily, you have to address all my concerns
and you also have to...
I'm interested in how you're
gonna sweeten the deal."
She's like, "What do you mean?
You want me to pay you?"
No, I'm like, "well, are
you to make a commitment
to watching movies with me that I want?"
Oh, bribing.
Yeah, like bribe me.
Like, "I want us to watch
some movies together
that are my choosing.
I want you to have a good
attitude when we watch them."
Okay, interesting.
I was like, "This is an
opportunity to force her
to cultivate our relationship.
And you need to pull out all the stops.
Also you need to give me carte blanche
to exploit anything associated
with this experience
for entertainment
purposes on Ear Biscuits."
Yeah, well, that's a given.
It wasn't a given cause
she tells me not to talk
about stuff all the time.
Just kidding.
So that brings us to now.
Okay. All right.
I'm gonna throw what might be
a complicating wrench
into this a little bit,
'cause I'm not sure that in
any of these presentations
I can't vouch for the
second one is very long.
If the issue of toxoplasmosis
has been addressed.
No, it has not.
I have not.
I may have heard the term--
Prepare to have your mind blow.
In preparation for that,
I will just say we've
gotten to a point where,
because she's been so passionate about it,
and we know what...
We're very open to trying out this kitten.
I think at this point
in this conversation,
I'm predicting that we're
going to get the kitten
on a trial basis.
It has not happened.
And I don't know if it will happen,
but if I had to put money on it,
I think that's what's gonna happen.
Okay. Now let me--
I kind of like cats.
Let me premise this with the fact that,
again, I have a soft spot for cats now.
I've already told you that
my "Hatred of cats," was mostly a bit.
I'm just a dog guy that preferred them.
And I did recently fall deeply in love
with the cat that is now dead.
All that being said,
I knew about this whole
toxoplasmosis thing before.
And I'm sure that if
you're a big cat lover,
you're gonna get upset with me.
Is this--
'Cause I'm bringing something up that
you may think is unfair or whatever.
But it's absolutely fascinating
and it's amazing how prevalent it is,
but people don't really
talk about it that much.
So there's a single cell
in microscopic organism called T gondii.
I don't know if I'm saying that right,
but it's not a bacteria or a virus,
but it is distantly
related to the parasite
that causes malaria.
Cats get T gondii and the disease
it causes is toxoplasmosis
by eating infected rodents,
birds and other animals.
Estimate suggested about 40% of cats
in the United States are infected.
Most don't show any symptoms,
but they can develop jaundice or blindness
and experienced personality changes
if the parasite spreads to
the liver or nervous system.
Now let me explain how this thing works.
So the theory on this is that--
You're trying to gross me
out of getting a kitten.
This particular organism evolved.
It only can reproduce in the
digestive tract of a cat.
That's the only place that
it can actually undergo
its reproduction process.
So it's got to get into the poop of cats.
And then it's got to get back into
a cat's digestive system.
So what it has developed is an adaptation
whereby when it gets
into a rat or a mouse,
cysts grow on the neurons,
inside the mice brain
and causes the rodent to
lose it's fear of cat piss.
So mice and rats--
They're repelled by the--
They're repelled by cat piss.
And if they get toxoplasmosis,
not only are they not repelled by it,
but some studies suggest
that they're into it,
that they're attracted to it.
And as you can imagine--
So the cat opens it's mouth,
well it's pee hole and it walked right in.
So they lose their fear
of cats, essentially,
which makes them an easy target,
which gets the toxoplasmosis or gets
the T gondii back into the
digestive tract of the cat
and the process starts all over again.
Now--
How does it get in the rat or the mice,
because they drink the pee?
It's in the poop, it's not in the pee
and poop is everywhere.
Cat's got poop--
And the rats eat the cat poop?
You end up getting fecal
matter in your mouth sometimes.
It's just all people, it just happens.
And if you're a rat,
you probably get a lot.
Then make it about you.
Say, "I get rat poop in my mouth."
11% of people in the United States
are infected with T gondii.
So one out of every 10 people is infected.
Good gosh.
The rates are much higher in regions
where people eat more raw meat
or sanitation is poor for example,
infection rates exceed 90% in some parts
of Europe and South America.
I've heard that something
like the vast majority...
I've heard somebody talk about Brazil
has a lot of people
infected with T gondii.
Now, in healthy people,
toxoplasmosis often
causes a flu like illness
or no symptoms at all,
but it can occasionally
be dangerous or even fatal
in those with weakened immune systems,
antibiotics can treat
the infection though,
drugs may not completely
banish the parasite.
Now this is where it starts getting crazy,
so I saw an article in the
New York Times, years ago,
where somebody is talking about this,
basically that crazy cat
lady is a real thing.
So somebody who lives with a bunch of cats
and is almost assuredly been of infected
by T gondii has toxoplasmosi,
actually undergoes behavioral changes
because of the infection.
They're happy?
And some people say,
well, they could develop an
attraction towards cat urine,
but the research on this,
the data is really incomplete because
you can't really conduct
a controlled study
on cat people in an ethical way.
But there's a lots of
research that suggests
that there are behavioral changes.
And let me just talk about some
of these behavioral changes
that might be the case.
Again, this isn't an exact science.
Jaroslav Flegr an evolutionary biologist
at Charles University
in the Czech Republic
is looking into this issue.
He has spent years studying
toxos impact on human behavior.
He found for example,
that people infected with
toxoplasmosis have slower reflexes
and are 2.5 times as likely
to get into car accidents.
I might already have it.
Toxoplasma gondii infection is thought
to alter the personalities
of infected individuals,
whether rats or humans by
increasing risk, taking behaviors.
Studies have shown that this can be--
So you take risks and you'd
have a slower reaction time.
That's not a good combination.
Studies have shown that this
can lead to more accidents.
But on the flip side, this
is where it gets tricky.
Stephanie Johnson and colleagues,
I don't know who that is,
but it's in this article.
Recently--
They have more fun.
Showed that this risk
taking tendency can lead
to increase entrepreneurial behaviors.
So you gotta take this into account.
Now, the--
Crazy cat lady entrepreneur.
So it gets weird, but the chances are,
especially if your daughter
has a cat poop receptacle
in her closet, that is--
That she's going to
become a business owner.
Surely getting on her clothes,
which may become business suits.
You got to think about the
fact that she's gonna get
a little potentially riskier
and you gotta be comfortable with that.
And she may be on the cover
of Forbes magazine one day and thank you.
But also you're probably
gonna get infected.
Only 11% of people in the
United States have it.
But if the cat never goes
out and eats raw flesh,
then the cat's not gonna get it.
You can't control a cat, you know that.
40% of all cats have it,
that's a low estimate.
They're called house cats,
you don't let them outside.
40% of all cats.
That's almost a coin flip.
Globally but--
No.
In United States.
It's a coin flip.
It's a coin flip whether
or not you're gonna
have toxoplasmosis and your
family, and your own brain.
There's an upside to it.
I just want you to be prepared.
Do not mention this to Christy.
Wow.
You just can't be part of it.
Okay, I'm just telling you that.
Especially if she's got it in the closet,
she's gonna get it.
You're right, the cat has to contract it,
which it's probably gonna happen, and--
I know that cat people are
screaming at you right now.
So I'm gonna...
I know there's gotta be a balance in fact,
but hey, I appreciate you bringing this up
because I will need to
achieve a comfort level
on this approach.
I'm not saying listen, to
all of that being given.
And like I said, the science
is not super established,
but this isn't fringe theory stuff.
I've heard of it.
With all that being said,
they think that if you take
the world's population into account,
I think that more than
half of the entire world
is already infected with this,
already has toxoplasmosis.
So it isn't like--
Let's go all in.
It's not like that big of a deal.
Some people, it can be a big deal.
So this would not preclude
me from getting a cat.
If I were to get a cat,
I wouldn't be like,
"Oh, toxoplasmosis."
I like taking risks, man.
And now we're two Rhett because
if my memory serves me correctly
before Lily discovered Jade,
and then we decided to adopt her,
you said, "I think we're gonna get a dog."
You told me that you as a family,
you were heads up, "I think
we're gonna get a dog."
And then I ended up getting
a dog before you because--
You moved into your new house before.
Yeah, because what we said is--
When you move into the
house, we'll probably get it.
We had said the whole time that
we were living in our old house,
we were like, "This is a
rental, we can't have a dog--"
That was the reason.
"When we buy a house,
we're gonna get a dog."
And it was like this...
Because he couldn't--
Multiple year lead up to
like, the kids were like,
"We're gonna get a dog.
We're gonna get a dog
as soon as we move."
Dog.
And so we did.
So I think there's a repeated thing like,
you had a connection with
a cat you've softened.
Then Lily shows up with a cat.
And by the way, update on Yeti.
After the first presentation,
Yeti was adopted.
Okay, that's relevant.
But there was another
one that she was like,
"You know what? There's another one."
There's always another cat.
This one's a black cat.
I was like, "Oh, now we got luck coming in
or lack of luck."
She's like, "This one's
gonna be even better.
This one's more laid
back, this one's black,
I'm gonna call this one Opal.
So we're gonna have Jade and Opal."
Oh, interesting.
Opals can be many colors,
but the most valuable
color is black, she said.
Anyway, I think you're gonna get cat.
Well, the dynamics--
Out of courtesy, I'm just giving you
a heads up that you know
what's gonna happen.
Well, the dynamics are similar.
Here's what I'll say,
my family, everyone, but
me really wants another dog
and has wanted another
dog for a long time.
And I want another dog.
And I like the idea, but I don't know.
I feel like I'm the only one in my family
with a real grasp of the
negatives that come along
with having another being
in the house, and the poop.
But we don't really have much of a yard,
we've got a little
artificial grass in one spot.
And that's where Barbara
does her business.
And Barbara's a little dog.
You're gonna double the business.
Jessie will put out pictures of--
A huge dog.
Giant sheep dog,
like she put doodles or stuff like that.
Like, "It just looks like a Teddy bear."
I'm like, "Could you imagine
the size of the ted?"
All I can see when I see that dog,
you see cute giant Teddy bear.
I see giant pieces of shit.
Now--
That's what I see.
That's not the case with a cat.
You're right.
But to me it's an adventure,
breaking the seal on having
an animal in the house
was a very rewarding experience for me.
And I'm so glad that we got Jade.
I have positive experiences with cats.
I'm curious, I think
it would be really cool
if they could be friends.
Again, if they can't, I
don't think it will work.
And then I'm like,
"I think we can still get
another dog, I don't know."
Maybe like a farm eventually.
Well, a farm that only has pets.
That's fun though.
Can I read you a list of names?
These are famous people.
Some people are dog people,
and some people are cat people.
And if you feel like you're
connecting with the people
who have been determined to be cat people,
maybe that's a sign that
you should go the cat way.
Or maybe you should
just stay the dog route.
Yes, you can read me this list.
Martha Stewart.
What's the question?
Do I like Martha Stewart?
When I say Martha Stewart--
Do I identify with her?
Do feel like there's
a kinship with her
spirit in some percents?
You could vibe with her
because I'm gonna tell you
whether she's a dog
person or a cat person.
I would have said no,
but in seeing all of her
colabs with Snoop dog,
she's changed my mind.
And now at the last
second I'm gonna say yes.
I could have a connection
with Martha Stewart.
Martha Stewart is a dog person.
Oh.
Speaking of Snoop Dogg, Snoop Dogg.
Would I connect with Snoop Dogg?
Yeah.
I'd love to. Yes.
Ironically, Snoop dog is a cat person.
What?
Okay, so now I'm 50 50.
Okay, all right.
But Jade is like a cat,
that's the confusing thing.
John Lennon.
John Lennon, I'm a McCartney man, no.
John Lennon is a cat person.
Yeah.
Seeing I don't think in my mind, I'm like,
"If I don't like somebody,
I'm assuming they're a cat person."
'Cause I know I'm a dog person.
It's just, am a both person?
All right, Oprah.
Boy, I would be intimidated.
But then I think she would
make me relax right off the bat
and we'd be in a cushy couch together.
And we'd be like...
I think within 10 minutes
of hanging out with Oprah,
we'd be holding hands.
You know how when you hold
both hands with somebody
and you're looking right into their eye,
having a conversation.
I would love to do that with Oprah.
I've never done that with anybody.
But Oprah would be the person
I would have both of
her hands in my hands.
I think my hands will be in her hands.
Oh, she's in control for sure.
Yeah, my hands are in her hands
and my eyes are locked on her eyes.
And then maybe my head
is resting on her bosom
after a couple hours.
That feels like a connection.
Yes.
Oprah is a dog person.
Lady Gaga.
Like in a getup or without makeup?
'Cause--
As Stephanie.
Yeah, definitely.
I want to connect with her.
I've connected with everybody, haven't I?
I believe so.
Yeah, I wanna meet her too, man.
Lady Gaga is a dog person.
Isn't that surprising?
I know she drives a pickup.
Katy Perry.
I know she dated John Mayer.
That's long ago.
Is this my end with John Mayer?
Not anymore, no.
Katy Perry is a cat person.
Yeah.
Freddie Mercury.
Freddie Mercury, man, what a talent?
What?
What a talent?
I think it's one of those
don't meet your heroes kind of thing.
I think I admire him too much to meet him.
So you don't think you
would dive with them?
No.
Freddie mercury is a cat person.
You're skewing dog right now.
Just so you know, you're skewing dog.
I'm skewing dog.
I'm not getting rid of my dog though.
The Rock.
He's tough, I just don't know.
I don't think so.
The Rock is a dog person.
And finally, Vanna White.
What a talent?
Myrtle beach girl.
Definitely, definitely.
I'd be strolling on the beach.
Christy would be there.
But say are you in a
relationship with Vanna?
'Cause that's what it sounded like.
No, it's a double date situation.
It's a triple date 'cause my--
Was Jack there?
No.
They're not a couple.
I know her husband but whatever.
What do you think her husband is like?
Do you think he's known
as Vanna White's husband?
I think it's like a Dolly
Parton's husband's situation.
Low profile?
Yeah, you just don't know.
It's like is he covered in tattoos?
Right.
I've heard.
Well, I don't know.
The rumor is that Dolly's
covered in tattoos,
not her husband.
I think her husband has--
Really?
Has a lot of tattoos.
You definitely connect with Vanna?
Yeah, yeah, triple date.
My dad and his wife are also there.
We're all strolling down the beach.
Vanna White is a cat person.
We're strolling on the
beach with a bunch of cats.
Bunch of cats.
So I wasn't keeping score,
but I think maybe that demonstrates
that you've got openness to both.
It's better to something you did.
and something you didn't.
Okay. But not having a cat at your house
that you don't--
People talk--
That doesn't really
apply to this situation,
I don't think.
People talk about--
Because once you have a
cat, you have the cat.
Cats like--
For a long time.
Like the reputation of a cat,
even if I hate the cat, it's like I have
a first person experiential
knowledge of that.
I've only heard all this stuff about cats.
I wanna experience that for myself.
I wanna take out a bite out of that pie
is how I feel about I'm
like, "Let's just go for it
and see what happens."
Well, I do think that you.
But do it responsibly,
do it safely that yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would say that the one
thing that is definitely true
in Lily's presentation is the level
of commitment is way less.
Because your day to day
with a dog, there's so much.
Yeah.
There's so much responsibility
because the dog needs so much,
the cat doesn't need as much from you.
So I do think that getting
a dog, that's a problem.
If the cat doesn't need me,
I'm not gonna like it, I will say that.
But I'd like to know.
Getting a dog that is a
problem dog is a bigger...
Again, I'm saying this is a dog owner.
That makes sense to me.
I think it's a bigger responsibility
or a bigger pain in the
ass than getting a cat.
That's a problem cat.
That just doesn't like you.
Most people have cats, it's like,
"Yeah, we don't touch him.
We would just set the food
out, he roams around."
After a while it's like,
"Okay, that's the way that cat is."
I think Steve's cat is a little like that,
but I always see the
cat in the background.
I need to talk to her about it.
Yeah, okay.
So no final decision.
I'll keep you updated and
exploit it for entertainment
as much as possible because
that is a wide silver lining.
For sure.
Definitely in my profession,
it's better to regret something you did
than something you didn't do?
What percentage of my contribution
to the entertainment value of what we do
is based on my personal regrets?
I've never thought of
that, but more than mine.
All right. I feel good about that.
Yeah. Do you have a wreck?
Oh shit.
Forgot about the wreck.
I'm excited about your wreck.
I've told you about this
because I texted you...
We weren't watching survivor one night,
'cause everybody wasn't there.
And I don't like watching survivor unless
all of the family's there.
Including the cat.
And so it was me and Lando and Christy.
And we were like...
I'm just like browsing and
it was close to bedtime.
I was like, "We might have time to watch
like a 22 minute Sitcom."
And then I saw this thumbnail on Netflix
and the runtime of the thing...
It looked like a movie, but
the runtime was 16 minutes.
So I'm like, "This is strange.
A 16 minutes thing on Netflix,
a short film type situation."
But I was so drawn in
by the thumbnail of it
that I was like, "Let's
watch this, it's short.
If it sucks, it's fine."
John Was Trying To Contact Aliens.
That's what it's called.
It's got this guy with a
long hair and a long beard.
And he's got what I
would call the crazy eye
from the life aquatic with Steve Zhu,
and they'll talk about that.
And I'm like, "This looks interesting.
After I watched it, I texted you.
I know your bedtimes later than mine."
I just knew you would like it.
So I was like, "Watch John
Was Trying To Contact Aliens
on Netflix it's 16 minutes.
You can do it before your bed time."
And I did it in the morning
while I was watching breakfast,
I was eating breakfast.
I've never watched Netflix
while eating breakfast.
Well, I was coming in and I was like,
It's 16 minutes and it's
probably something funny
to talk about, so I'll just watch it.
I think Netflix is onto something
with these shorter videos.
I think they could just
have shorter videos
and they could be more personality based
But if you have commenting underneath
and video replies.
So make it YouTube?
Yeah.
It's just like an interestingly
edited biopic, not biopic.
It's just a documentary of this guy, John,
and like the middle of nowhere
who has devoted his entire
life to contact aliens.
And there's a defining
moment in the documentary
that we're not going to spoil.
I'm not gonna spoil it.
The only thing I'll say is
that while watching breakfast,
why am I saying watching breakfast?
Yep.
Is that what happens
when you watch Netflix.
While eating breakfast with my wife,
watching this 16 minute short film.
When the thing that you're talking about
that we will not spoil happened,
my eyes welled up with tears.
I would just think it was 16 minutes long,
it was touching, it was touching.
We were giving away too much already
because the best thing is
to go in totally blind.
So forget everything we
said, except to watch it.
Yeah, 16 minutes of your time.
That's all we ask and a hundred...
Well, how many minutes
we've been gone right now?
Sometimes we ask a little bit less.
Sometimes we ask a little bit more.
Thanks for being on the journey with us.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.